hi my name is Mason and I'm an ex subway
employee and today I will be matching
people to their Subway sandwiches when
it comes to Subway there's a lot of
different options and many different
ingredients to choose from with how you
want to make your sandwich so it's gonna
be a little tough today but I'm gonna
interrogate them a little bit trying to
figure out as best as I can
who subway order goes with who so we'll
see what happens fingers crossed bring
in the customers
I'm here to interrogate you I'm gonna
figure this out I'm gonna try all right
so we've got three sandwiches here we've
got a footlong spicy Italian on honey
oat and this consists of double cheese
pepper jack toasted lettuce spinach
tomato onion banana peppers jalapenos
marinara sauce from the meatballs oh
yeah Parmesan cheese oregano salt and
pepper then we have the meatball
marinara meatballs
marinara sauce Parmesan cheese and then
the last one I believe is the subway
melt and it's turkey ham bacon American
cheese toasted lettuce onions jalapenos
sweet onion and mayo so let's get down
to it and see which one is your sandwich
of choice how often do you go to Subway
funny story with that I was an athlete
in college and they abused us going to
subway that was like every single meal
after game was subway and I was fine
with it my teammates hated it
but I was like I ordered the same thing
since the ninth grade so I'm all my gosh
what are your three favorite types of
foods
Asian soul food Italian whoo
I was wondering if she was gonna say it
out he bought marinara there is Italian
how do you feel about pickles I like
pickles pickled onions
well this has led me nowhere
she's stared at the veggie sandwich she
likes Italian so there's the meatball
marinara and then she likes onions too
which is all over that subway melts so
how much would you say you typically
spend on a sandwich um on this
sandwiches I usually get a cookie I get
my little macadamia nuts with it okay so
I'd say it's like about 12 bucks okay so
I'm assuming you get a footlong then
yeah I'm I like food I don't think it's
the marinara I don't think it's the
meatball I'm gonna say between these two
I'm kind of more confident on this one
just because she says she spends around
$12 so one last part of the
interrogation I just want you to read
off yes this list of ingredients like
you're ordering from me okay hi how are
you welcome to subway can I get a subway
melt with turkey ham bacon American
cheese can I have it toasted with
lettuce onions jalapenos sweet onion and
mayo this isn't her sandwich God give me
this it's not her sandwich back to the
drawing board I think I've learned a lot
and I think I've learned nothing at all
at the same time so let's move on to the
next person and hopefully I can actually
figure something out here - I'm Lea nice
to meet ya I mean all of them look
really delicious yeah and I
you know I eat nothing at Subway anymore
but kudos to you why don't you eat
anything at Subway Oh God
that is a whole different video would
you say you are when it comes to food
very adventurous but yes I am pretty
adventurous that way doesn't give me as
much adventure as I want to but it's so
convenient and you always know what
you're gonna get you can be adventurous
in some way that's not true that's not
true because sometimes I put those like
peppers on there I'm like why did I do
this okay
I think I have an idea but we're gonna
keep going
would you consider yourself a meter or
not I'm actually cutting back on the
meat oh yeah okay I'm trying not to eat
as much like red meat and pork okay I do
like the birds the poultry really weird
based on that I want to take out the
marinara I feel like I'm always taking
out the marinara first and this has meat
on it and she says she's trying to cut
back not very adventurous when it comes
to vegetables in my sandwich but Oh
oh my god this changes everything now
okay how much do you usually spend on
when you go to Subway how much do you
spend on yeah what up the good one cuz
you're gonna eliminate all the meat yeah
I'd say about tax five to seven dollars
I spend on my sandwiches do you order
anything else it's that just on the
sandwich I really like the cookies at
Subway so you get a cookie either two or
three or ten how many things are you
buying so I want to do one last test I'm
gonna have you pick up each sandwich by
the wrapper and give it a smell little
sniff yeah okay see which one you're
most into
I was really good she's trying to throw
me off it's not gonna work that's a
hefty sail she well she is heavy she's
thin she's a thick um um I like the snow
that one that one smells good so does
that one feel like I'm being thrown off
by this one how do I know you're not
acting so I have my suspicions but we
will see at the end hello Mason I'm
Brendan I will be taking your order
today Oh wonderful figuring out what
sandwich belongs to you how often do you
eat at Subway
I eat at Subway probably like I sell it
once or twice a month
I do like Subway okay so your your
Subway fan big fan of what you guys do
okay well then how much do you usually
spend on just the sandwich alone
not including Li chips inserted I don't
know cuz I'm normally buying for me and
my girlfriend so it's like it varies
usually like a couple sandwiches worth
how much is it for long is like they're
not five dollars anymore like six
something sick something I would say
typically I don't know cuz then it's
like what if we get six inches that
there's there's a range right I would
say I'm coming out for less than 20
bucks per visit how do you feel about
pickled foods as a concept onions
do you like them I'm pretty at the Fed
will wait is that gonna be a you're
tricking me hold on no I mean fine okay
with my I'm like I'm relatively
apathetic about I don't I don't love or
hate them which is not very useful to
you know that is I think I'm gonna roll
out this footlong spicy Italian one
because he noted that it was a lot going
on so maybe that might be intimidating
for you and two because it has a lot of
pickled items on it I don't want to say
I'm intimidated but not intimidated go
crazy it's a lot going on it's a little
extra it's a pretty busy sandwich then
there's the meatball marinara which I
have yet to assign to anyone might be
you Aryan are you listen Mason I can't
rule anything out at this point
do you eat meat I eat meat yes okay so
he doesn't eat meat so I'm gonna rule
out the melt I'm tired of giving
everyone the melt so we're gonna no
we're not gonna do the melt okay I'm
gonna say you're the meatball marinara
why do you think I'm the meatball
marinara cuz you like meat and I think
you like to keep things simple and this
one isn't as simple so I'm thinking it's
the meatball Mariner so I think I know
enough now to finally make a final
decision on whose sandwiches who so
let's bring everybody back in okay time
for my final decision first we're going
to start with Brendan could you step
forward please
I believe your sandwich is the meatball
marinara so I'm going to hand you this
we can do so much and I hope that's
correct
this one was a very hard one hmm but I
think I'm gonna go with the spicy
Italian unhung a coat yeah whatever and
last but not least Leah can you step
forward please I just feel like the way
lifted the sandwich like you knew what
you were doing and that could be a very
shallow reasoning but I'm gonna go ahead
and give you the subway melt and guess
that this is yours
no I guess we're going to find out the
results and see if I got anyone right
hopefully I got one right let's start
with Brendan
I do love a mimosa but this is not my
sandwich you're right I'm a pretty low
maintenance guy except when it comes to
my Subway sandwiches because this bad
boys oh my god I'm hurt I should have
known
yeah it's also like huge and I'm very
large like there is I should have I
should have known that because when I
worked at Subway a lot of like a bigger
guys are coming not that you're a bigger
guy but I mean like tall guys would come
in and get like these very hefty
sandwiches so it makes sense yeah you
should have one with your initial gut
you had me pegged from the beginning and
then you just didn't do it I am a subway
milk kind of girl I've fooled myself you
fooled me though I read it you you read
it like you had never read it before so
okay you know I threw you off a little
bit
I do like a meatball marinara but I you
said you weren't a vegetable person I
didn't like a whole veggie sandwich well
I got no one right today which is what I
expected so I'm not as hurt because I'm
very bad at guessing and I knew this
from the start
I got everything so wrong today but it's
okay cuz you know as long as everyone
has their sandwiches and they're happy
then that's all that matters
[Music]